okay earlier in the show I told you that
a new report says Vladimir Putin gave
direct instructions to help elect Donald
Trump on November 8 2016 and a question
for many people has been what is Donald
Trump doing that is so helpful to Putin
and Russia anyway if Putin did try to
influence the election and if Putin did
successfully influence the election it
hasn't been really a great thing for
Putin because Trump has done nothing to
help Russia and of course the answer to
that is wrong in a general sense
russia's investment in trump during the
election is actually paying off we have
multiple US intelligence agencies which
are basically unanimous that Russia
meddled with the election they were
involved in hacking emails and other
systems and the goal of it was help
elect Trump win okay it was reported
Friday that Putin was directly involved
in that campaign so now the question is
what has been done that has been
beneficial to Russia
number one we already know that on the
eve of the Republican National
Convention right around that time
Trump's campaign had the influence of
making the Republican platform more
Russia friendly we saw throughout the
entire campaign and even since the
election of Donald Trump that Trump is
basically with very few exceptions
refusing to say bad things about Russian
President Vladimir Putin praising him
sometimes and again we're talking about
a brutal authoritarian leader who
appears to have the blood of journalists
on his hand so right off the bat we've
got that right away we also have
reported on the fact that in the first
days of Donald Trump's presidency his
administration was trying to lift the
sanctions on Russia there was a plan
involving a disgraced national security
adviser Michael Flynn and Trump's lawyer
Michael Cohen who now himself has
lawyered up too as quickly as possible
lift those sanctions that's great for
Russia although it hasn't yet happened
Vladimir Putin also sees NATO as an
adversary Donald Trump has come out
against NATO multiple times in multiple
ways more recently taking a more prone
8'o approach but still refusing to say
hey we should stand by article 5 this
idea that an attack against any NATO
nation is an attack again
all NATO nations that something Putin
likes and then of course you have the
other ways in which Donald Trump's aides
have undermined the European Union and
we've outlined those before and most
recently you have Trump number one
working to return those compounds back
to Russia in New York and Maryland which
President Obama had seized from Russia
for interference in the election and you
also have Donald Trump inexplicably
spilling sensitive national security
intelligence from our ally Israel to
Russian diplomats including a suspected
Russian spy recruiter in the Oval Office
that's kind of a lot of stuff isn't it
Pat yeah I know you have that list of
the many ways that Trump has helped the
Russians but aside from making him the
leader of the free world of the Pres the
president United States how is Russia
really helped Trump you know aside from
that one thing they've done very little
other than that yeah I think that's so
what Pat has just blown a whole wide
open in the entire and the entire
hypothesis a few other quick things
Trump backed out of the Paris climate
climate agreement Russia likes that
right I mean Russia likes taking
prestige and power away from the EU and
the EU led Paris agreement is something
that Vladimir Putin doesn't like and
Donald Trump backing off of that is
something that certainly pleases
Vladimir Putin and so what do we have we
have a situation where if Moscow helped
Donald Trump win in order to get things
from Donald Trump things are basically
going exactly as planned from them at
for them and maybe the biggest win for
Vladimir Putin and Russia is that
American politics are paralyzed right
now barely anything is happening it's
been a struck the tab who's talking
about the tax plan the affordable care
act for the American Health Care Act
part two after a long hiatus is now
potentially back on the table but think
they have they have truly paralyzed our
political system and that's probably the
biggest advantage for Russia right now I
think it's also entirely possible that
had this whole Trump Russia scandal not
gotten so much exposure
yes kept under wraps that we would have
seen a lot more like perhaps the 500
billion dollar oil deal with ExxonMobil
would have gone a lot more
than it is now there's a dozen or so
things that have been seemingly
interrupted by the fact that these
investigations have been building no
doubt about that and and I know someone
will email me and they'll say but David
Trump has done things that Russia
wouldn't like like he did bomb that
Syrian regime Airport and Putin supports
the Syrian regime Trump bombed a
meaningless airport for show and the
airport was back up and running within
hours of the strike and he notified the
Russians that he was going to do that
that's exactly right probably a good
thing because you don't want any
international conflicts to spur out of
that if that's what you're going to
email me with save it by all means
please save it